In the last video, we talked
about how the Serbians were
able to hold back
the Austro-Hungarians
at the beginning of World
War I. But eventually
they had to give in.
They couldn't hold up
against the combined forces
of the Bulgarians,
the Austro-Hungarians,
and the Germans.
And they were able to
roll through in 1915.
And then we wait until
1918 for the Allies
to essentially recapture Serbia.
Now what is noteworthy-- there's
many noteworthy things in World
War I and obviously we
can't cover all of them--
is just what a
huge loss World War
I was to the Serbian people.
Just as a little bit of
context, very small country--
we're talking 4.5 million people
as we enter into World War I--
with a reasonably,
I guess relative
to the size of the country,
it was a decent-sized army.
But with an army we're
talking on the order
of 400,000 soldiers.
And this was pretty much
everyone in the country who
could be in the army was
essentially in the army.
Over the course of
the Serbian campaign
and the Macedonian
front, you essentially
have the Serbian army
getting decimated.
You have 60% of the
Serbian army dies.
Roughly 60% of the
Serbian army is killed.
And even from a
population point of view,
the Serbian population
is reduced by 16%.
16% of the Serbian population,
civilian and military,
is dead by the end
of World War I.
So a lot of countries
suffered horribly
during World War I. There's
many notable ones, France,
the Russian Empire.
We could go on and on and on.
But it would be hard to argue
that any country suffered
more than what the Serbians did.
60% of their military dead,
16% of their population.